the host of USA Network's NFL football
fanatic the host of The Voice in
Australia a Scottish born Australian
Darren McMullen good to see you sir good
to see you how are you I am great so
just introducing you to those who may
not know your work in Australia so you
do the voice in Australia this is your
the Carson Daly of that of that or
pardon me
Carson Daly is the Darren McMullen
that's right I did the voice I don't do
the voice anymore so I moved to
Australia as a teenager and then ended
up getting in TV hosting in my 20s and
okay did I start with MTV actually like
Carson Daly I guess I did the canna the
TRL version in Australia was called the
layer and then did kind of Entertainment
Tonight style shows and minute to win it
if you remember that show that Guy Fieri
did here I did that in in Australia and
then I also did that in the UK did a
talk show for ITV an Olympic sports
based talk show and a kind of big shiny
floor magic show called The Magicians
which is kind of like Dancing with the
Stars but with magicians all right
famous magicians with celebrity guests
you know and when I did SportsCenter for
seven years we would be talking you know
having fun and making pop-culture
references and and and on occasion
poking a little bit of fun of people and
then we caught wind of the way that
Australian sports presenters would talk
about sports down there and it made us
blush of how harsh it can possibly be
and how much fun they make of some of
the athletes and some of the moments
down there I mean it did any of that rub
off on you I think you clothes were that
kind of sarcastic Canada yeah oh they
don't hold back
oh even on the news you'll have news
anchors having a dig it's some story
they just yeah kind of presented on
serious stories sometimes moretz that
Ozzy larrikin sensibility and quite
similar to the Scottish as well that way
they like a friendly banter it's all
friendly though right so now you come up
with the idea of like hey I'd like to go
into the world of the NFL and just throw
myself in and as a blank slate right
seems like a scam of the century doesn't
it here's a way to get all access passes
and meet all the best players in the
league and
travel the country for free and make a
TV show about it hmm
scam of the century right so how many
teams have you visited with Horry we
visited that the idea was really I I
brought my girlfriend back she's an
American she's from Detroit to Scotland
for the first time and she was just
blown away by the countryside by where I
went to school the fact we had castles
and the greens and the whole bit and I
refill in love with my country through
seeing it okay through her eyes and I
thought you know what what it what a
great way to approach this show you know
sometimes you really don't know what you
have because you take it for granted
until you see it with an outsider's I so
this football fanatic was a love story
of mine to America I grew up as a young
kid watching and if a football fell in
love with America knew I wanted to live
there one day and now I do but I never
had a team I just loved the game and I
thought you know what I'm gonna travel
this amazing country I'm gonna see all
32 teams learn about the history the
rituals the superstitions the cities
that encapsulate them the different
foods they eat and based on that I'm
gonna pick a team that that melds well
with my sensibilities I don't have to
pick a team based on who my family
supports like I wouldn't Scotland
otherwise I'd get kicked out and the
doors would be changed right I don't
have to pick a team based on geography
cuz when I came up with his show there
wasn't a team in LA and I lived in LA so
there's two no there's two but I've
already you know went on this mission
now I have to finish it I need to finish
it and and I really want to pick a team
with passionate fans
I hate Fairweather fans I love real
red-blooded fans or they bleed the color
of their team you know the guys that
stayed at the final whistle even if
they're down sure the guys that are
always there because I went through that
in Scotland you know we we've been my
team lost for dramatically for nine
years there was just a really sad state
of affairs but they came back and and
those wins are so much tastier it's like
you said you're a Jets fan
yeah the Jets actually win something
know how good that's gonna be see now
it's I mean we'll all be dead by then
but you know okay great see now it's
difficult for me to handle that coming
from somebody from outside of this
country who says that the person close
to you in your life is a Lions fan kind
of tough to swallow that a bitter pill
right now
honest with you but it's fair it's fair
so of the eight teams that you've seen
so far I think I've got the list of them
here right Atlanta and Dallas Green Bay
and Seattle yeah
Giants and Eagles Chiefs and ramps
that's right I mean you want to talk
about some of the loudest buildings are
talking about Seattle in Kansas City
those are loud you want to talk about
passionate fan bases Packers are
mentioned up there with the Chiefs
Seahawks with the twelve
Philly Philly is well Mike's right yeah
next loss so which one so far if you had
to choose one yeah of the eight that you
as a NFL football fanatic which one
would you put your marker on right now
there's no way because you got to watch
the show reg that's that's the whole
point in the show okay and you know even
you know what this the show that this
aired already was Dallas and Atlanta and
I've had abuse of text messages from
people in Philly going not gonna lie it
made me vomit seeing you with a Cowboys
Jersey on I don't know if I can make it
to the to the this the affiliate Assad I
said look it's a bit like watching your
girlfriend sleep with someone else I get
it don't watch anything until we come to
Philadelphia right but I had to I had to
walk a mile in a fan shoes you know it
was a fully interactive experience okay
so that's what I wanted to do so I'm
going to enjoy week in week out I do
have my I do have ones I am leaning
towards but the the mission I the goal
is to see all 32 before I pick all right
so what's the best food well the best
food I would say Kansas City barbecue
knocked my socks off everybody would
rave about Kansas City barbecue and like
I live in Australia there the barbecue
kings I mean I'm good that's like they
do their breakfast lunch and dinner of
barbecues in Australia in the rain snow
Sun whatever right didn't we see
Crocodile Dundee 30 years ago about
putting shrimps on an actual Barbies on
the barbecue as they actually don't call
the shrimp's in Australia they call them
prawns but anyway yeah so I went the
first time I had a bite of those ribs
and I was like oh my it was like my
first drink of beer I was like wow it
was a whole new world just open all
right so the Chiefs get the chief they
get that they get absolutely that I
would say for just raw passion
mmm-hmm it would have to be Philly fans
I've never that level of intensity they
show for their their team
I haven't witnessed outside of Scotland
you know in Scotland you know we can't
even go in to the ground at the same end
of the city so when the the Darby's
happened Celtic and Rangers in Glasgow
one side of the city is you know it's
cut off by Mounted Police and one one
set of fans has to come in one side of
the city other side for the other fans
and we're segregated by fences and rows
and rows of police so I'm used to that
level of intensity Wow but III witnessed
that bit with that with the Philly fans
but it's funny wherever you go around
the country the teams didn't agree on
much but one thing all the teams did
agree on was all Philly fans dead be
careful when you go there and then you
go there you like you guys aren't that
bad it's like yeah everyone gives us a
hard time because we threw snowballs at
Santa Claus late 60s but Santa Claus
wears red and white sorry Santa you
missed the most important rule you don't
wear red to a Philadelphia Eagles game
there you go
just don't wear your green suit you'd be
fine all right so the Eagles get the
checkmark there yeah which game did you
see that was the best game cuz this is
all shot this season yeah what was it
was Green Bay who are they playing God
you get so caught up in the in the
actual the phone Aaron Rodgers active at
the time yeah yeah it was it was it was
week two
who do they who did the who did they
play week two they play well we do they
were in Atlanta I know that but seems
like week one they opening out in
Seattle and then Cincinnati was a really
intense game it was really good to
playoffs and went to overtime yes
Cincinnati that was the game we went to
see was he a Cincinnati Cincinnati
Bengals yes that was that was incredibly
sweet come from Cowboys Giants in Dallas
Charlotte Jones giving me the tour three
balls with that press guarding Coach
Garrett that's something that nobody
else from Scotland just saying hey I
want to see what the Cowboys are locker
gonna get you went straight up the
flowchart I know the weird thing about
that is rich I grew up in Scotland
loving NFL and our Center for a football
American football for Christmas and of
course I got it and none of my friends
knew what that was because it wasn't
more like we're not playing what is that
it's not round we can't play with that
right so I was quite often seen in my
backyard
being my own wide receiver and
quarterback and there I was an MVP
week-in week-out I thought you know what
if I was an American I would be a
quarterback for sure and I happened to
mention that to Coach Garrett and he
goes well why don't you throw it with
this guy that Brett I'll see what you
got I'll give you some I'll see if
you've got what it takes I'm like really
with that Prescott yeah so the first
time I ever had somebody to throw the
ball back it was dak Prescott and it
turns out not such a good quarterback
I dropped me threw me a bullet I dropped
it and then I'm nervous you know so like
I'm looking shaky a bit and trying to
throw it throwing like a four year old
kid in America would probably throw
that's great and and coach Garrett
Charlotte Jones is in a stairs going
okay we need to start from scratch what
is going on here I'm like well I don't
know in my backyard I was good pretty
intense situation you put me in that's
great man it's a on USA on Monday nights
the next one again is gonna be
back-to-back episodes Mondays at 11 and
11:30 p.m. Eastern the Packers and the
Seahawks and then the runs up to the
Super Bowl the next episode after that
Giants and Eagles bother
and then the Chiefs in the Rams yeah
look forward to it and then and then
when's the episode with the Scottish
claymores when is that well you never
went to never norway's the World League
of America never there's only American
football for me all the way never really
liked soccer much growing up American
sports just I don't know resonated with
me this was my spiritual home I need to
be here Darren thanks for coming on
thanks for having - no will you pick
eventually okay yeah you got a day I
want to drag this out for a few more
years first though there so I'm gonna do
all 32 okay three more seasons to come
up with good luck to you on that day
Darren McMullen on Twitter so Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience